a 15 year old
shot
three
of his four siblings
and then himself
and everybody is dead
and this is one of those cases i've said
before
you gotta charge the people that are
supposed to be in charge of the gun this
is a tragedy but you've got to charge
the people that are supposed to be in
charge of the gun
alaska news source reports
four children dead in fairbanks after 15
year olds shot three siblings and
himself per troopers
four children are dead
god what a tragedy
after a 15 year old turned a gun on
three of his siblings and then took his
own life that's per alaska state
troopers
this happened on tuesday
troopers got a report of a shooting at a
subdivision in north of fairbanks alaska
the troopers showed up and found four
kids dead from an apparent gunshot wound
troopers said that a fifteen-year-old
boy shot three siblings the siblings
are were aged 5 8 and 17
and then shot himself oh it's three
other siblings in the home were not
injured not one other three other
siblings in the home
so
the parents of the children and one
other sibling were also not i'm sorry
one sibling
three others is four and then the three
that were shot is seven and then eight
so you've got a house it's an it's a
very very small house there's images of
the house
uh in some of the news articles
you've got eight siblings and you've got
an unsecured gun
now there has not been a lot of detail
here but one of the questions is whose
gun was it and how did the 15 year old
get access to it well according to nbc
news
the gun was a family gun by the way the
term family gun that is uniquely
american
it was a family gun but beyond that it's
all still part of an ongoing
investigation
um
if indeed
i mean listen family gun the 15 year old
is not allowed to have the gun
so by family gun it probably means
that this was a firearm
that belonged to and was uh purchased by
the parent or parents
and if that's the case
the firearm being accessible to the 15
year old
would be
a negligent act by the parents by the
gun owners
and we often talk about when there are
these so-called accidental shootings
which are really negligent shootings
where the gun owner accidentally fires a
gun at someone we say well that's really
a tragedy and do we want to add
more to what is already a tragedy when a
dad accidentally shoots his own kid as
we've covered before
and the kid dies
that's the tragedy so do we really want
to go after the parent for a negligent
gun discharge
given that they've lost their kid well i
don't know it's not really my decision
to make
but further here we have a situation
where of of course this is a tragedy for
the parents
but what is the signal being sent
if the parents didn't properly store
and lock the firearm
and then it was accessible to a 15 year
old
who then killed three of his siblings
and himself
what's the message this that's sent if
the parents aren't charged
i don't know
uh
i'd like to hear from you about that
one other aspect in general and when you
have an individual incident here this is
an individual mass shooting
individual mass shootings and broader
statistics sometimes they correlate
sometimes they don't or whatever the
case may be
alaska has the number one gun homicide
rate in the country
the gun homicide rate in alaska is over
24 gun homicides
per 100 000 people now if you're
wondering whether 24 is high new york
and massachusetts the two states with
the lowest gun homicide rate
have a gun homicide rate of three
okay
consider that's we're talking about
seven times higher more than seven times
higher
uh the gun homicide rate is three
in new york and massachusetts and it's
more than 24 in alaska
it just so happens
that gun laws in alaska are not strict
and gun laws in new york and
massachusetts
are strict and once again we see that
correlation this one story is just an
anecdote but i think it's always
important to kind of pull out and to say
well what's the context in alaska and
what's the context in some of these
other states um for all of the you know
there's the the woke bashing that takes
place oh
new york is so dangerous and it's just
riddled with
urban gun crime euphemisms right
um
the
gun homicide rate in alaska
is extraordinarily high and anchorage
alaska is consistently
for uh among in the united states a very
dangerous metro area when it comes to
violent crime barely ever makes the news
i don't know if it doesn't fit with the
narrative of the right i don't know if
it's because alaska is so geographically
distant from the contiguous 48 states i
don't pretend to know exactly why
but that is the truth those are the
numbers and just another horrible
horrible tragedy
and if only we could do something about
this right
oh wait this is a problem that plagues
the united states and almost no other
wealthy western nation yeah make sure
you follow us on facebook for more on
this and other stories from today's show
facebook.com
slash david pakman show